what up space fam goals in here for
anime uproar and today we're going to be
talking about every commandments
backstory I recently talked about every
sins backstory and I love the feedback I
got from that video so it made sense to
tackle this one next if you enjoy seeing
seven deadly sins videos on this channel
and want to keep them coming make sure
to smash that like button and share this
video if you have it be sure to
subscribe and this is very very
important hit that notification bell
because if you don't you will not know
when future seven deadly sins videos
drop I'll actually go live with the
tournament bracket for the best
commandment before I publish this video
you'll be able to vote for who passes on
to the next round until there's only one
winner left you can vote via Instagram
stories at anime uproar hope to see you
there
lastly there will be manga spoilers in
this video so if that actually bothers
you you've been warned now without
further ado let's jump into it let's
start with the commandment of patience
droll the former king of Giants droll
was born differ from other giants most
Giants look like humans just Giganta
fide droll on the other hand was way
bigger than the other giants he had blue
skin a mysterious eye and forearms
rather than to control so big that he
even looks like a giant when compared to
our own cube giant the end he's almost
three times her size in fact she's
thirty feet tall and he's about 85 feet
tall if you actually want to get a sense
of how big troll would be in real life
you can check out the 84 feet tall giant
Santa statue unveiled in India's New
Delhi in 2017 humans literally look like
ants compared to that thing anyways for
all these different reasons drol was
treated as an outcast by the other
Giants they never let poor drole join in
any giant games nevertheless because he
was so strong they respected him after
all the Giants value strength above all
else droll eventually became the king of
the clan and always remained the highly
respected ancestor of the giant clan
drool came up with trolls dance a
special dance that increases a Giants
connection with the earth and in the
process increases their power
let's also explain his mysterious eye
while we're at it
Joel's mysterious eye lets him read
people's thoughts and power levels
Baylor's magical eye
Merlin's magical items is actually named
after droll and his own magic I baler is
what humans called the droll in his time
Joel was not only bigger and stronger
than all the other Giants his
earthbending was also much better he
could easily create giant labyrinths
from the ground and cancel out the
attacks of other Giants because of his
greater connection to the earth about
three thousand years ago he fought
against the demon clan as a member of
stigma along with the fairy king
gloxinia Mellie Otis and the goddess
Elizabeth droll was a warrior who aimed
to be the strongest he wanted to defeat
the demon king himself looking back this
was a pretty insane goal but it wasn't
insane in the giant king's head at the
time and his hopes and pride were
completely crushed when zelgius the
demon king's son completely and
effortlessly crushed droll despite being
insanely smaller than him it's like if a
fly beat you up worse than you've ever
been beaten up before zelgius gave troll
a choice he could either die or join the
10 commandments zelgius offers to grant
him even more power for droll and most
Giants running away isn't an option so
he only had two choices in his mind die
or what he decided to do become the
commandant of patience zelgius was
persuasive not only did he offer a
strength obsessed person a chance to get
stronger he also highlighted trolls
loneliness he called droll and outcast
among the Giants but he said the demons
are different because they are all
outcasts of the world of nature thus he
offered drill power and belonging and
roll took the deal eventually he was
sealed away by the goddesses along with
most of the other commandments next we
have the first fairy King gloxinia he
was born around four thousand four
hundred years ago meaning he was about
1400 when he got sealed away jihad is
his little sister and was born around
200 years after him they were really
close gloxinia cared about her a lot and
it his best to look after her she was
more important to him than his own life
three thousand years before the events
of the main story gloxinia was good
friends with troll and they were both
part of stigma with Mellie Otis and
Elizabeth Joel joined the demons because
he lost the fight but it was different
for gloxinia as meliodas points out
gloxinia was betrayed by those he
trusted he was robbed of something
valued more than his own life he left
row and the other humans to help protect
the fairy Kings forest but they did the
opposite because they were wrong by
stigma in the past they actually started
attacking the fairies and Giants when
they were supposed to be helping them
row actually had a change of heart when
one of his own people cut get had his
right eye he killed his own teammate to
save her bollocks Ania showed up he saw
what looked like a dying it had enrols
arms and blamed him for what happened to
her overcome by anger he ran his spear
spear through rose body killing him he
turned on the humans and stigma because
they weren't able to protect his sister
he thought that his sister was dead he
didn't even stop to make sure he joined
the 10 commandments and became the
Commandant of repose ironic because
repose or in other words a state of
tranquility is exactly what he was
missing he was eventually sealed away
along with troll and the others next
let's look at derrière II the
commandment of purity and won't speed
the commandment of reticence unlike the
other two we already mentioned these two
were in fact demons dairy area was 377
years old before she got sealed away and
moan speed was 415 before the holy war
she had an older sister her older sister
loved menthe speed all three of them
were really close but it seems like one
speed really had a thing for dairy Arry
quite the demonic love triangle then
about three thousand years ago their
areas older sister was one of the tens
of thousands of demons that Luna shall
kidnapped and used as live bait to
attract the other demons he kept them
trapped in suffering in giant orbs of
goddess magic derriere Ramon speed and
many other demons start moving in the
direction of the orbs because they can
sense the demon energy they meet the
goddess Elizabeth along the way who
knows nothing about the kidnapped demons
she does however know that Ludo shell is
planning something and for that reason
tells the demons to retreat Elizabeth
promises that if there really are demon
hostages she will get them released just
as the demon seemed about to retreat
Luna shell shows up and makes it look
like Elizabeth was just buying time for
the goddesses Lucia reveals the giant
Ark which is the name of that giant
goddess orb the goddess magic keeps all
the demons trapped in a state between
life and death
the energy is consistently eroding their
magic and flesh derriere he sees her
sister calling out to her before a lunar
shell closes his fist and in the process
kills derriere sister and the tens of
thousands of other demons in an instant
you can't even blame Guerrieri for
losing her cool and punching Elizabeth
she just washed her sister get killed by
the goddesses right before her eyes and
she was led to believe that Elizabeth
was in on it then the Archangels kill
many many more demons using the arc
magic but their Aryan won't speed along
with fraud Hren and Galan survive and
engage them in combat the demons do
pretty well against the two Archangels
Tarmey el and sorry el but things change
when the stronger lunar shell enters the
fray in order to beat him both their
area and won't speed sacrifice six of
their seven hearts in order to take on
the ultimate evil form called Endura
Andorra's are insanely powerful but they
lose their ability for rational thought
they become powerful beasts in their in
their forms they actually manage to
overwhelm the three Archangels including
Ludo she'll eventually Elizabeth would
sorry Elle's and Tom yells help ends up
saving both of them from their Endura
transformation and as a result they end
up reverting back to normal looter shall
then tries to kill them while they're
passed out but droll anglex Aeneas a the
two demons
despite being saved by Elizabeth won't
speed and arrey arrey go on to fight as
members of the ten commandments along
with the others they are sealed away for
3,000 years
next let's look at gray road the
commandant of pacifism gray road was 176
years old when she was sealed away 3,000
years ago with grey road there isn't
much to say about her backstory she's
technically genderless most lower level
demons are but because of grey roads
impress a level of power Roger first to
her as she rather than it Cray wrote is
a mutated gray demon she is surrounded
by darkness and made up of many small
great demons these great demons can
speak and act on their own as with the
other Commandments
she was sealed away 3,000 years ago
let's look at the land the commandment
of truth next Galland was 900 91 years
old before he got sealed away we don't
know much about Gallants backstory
before he showed up with very areum on
speed to fight the Archangels Goliath is
a classy elder as far as demons go he
and
loyd afternoon naps he loved wine and
his dream was to conquer britannia we
also know that galiyan was friends with
Perugia who sacrificed six of his hearts
and turned into the Endura of
retribution during the holy war this is
actually a pretty sad detail in the
seven deadly sins story when won't speed
and derrière he turned into Endura Galan
wanders about where his comrade Bharucha
is wandering about these days it's a
quick moment but it shows that the land
is deeper than we thought and he is
surprisingly sentimental when it comes
to the suffering of his comrades we see
Bharucha in the prisoners of the sky
movie and by this point Bharucha can no
longer think or act rationally he is a
mindless beast of destruction we'll
never get to know what Perugia was like
before he treated everything pretty in
dura power we know the rest of the
land's backstory through their area Mon
speeds backstory when they were first
attacked a land warned everyone to run
and even help save Mille ask Allah from
the Omega Ark attack he helped the
surviving demons get the upper hand
against army l and sorry l but that
lunar shell showed up and filled the
land with holes then he watches as
theory area Mons be turned into Endura
and sorry kicking but before Elizabeth
saves them from becoming mindless
monsters eventually Galan gets sealed
away with the rest of the commandments
next let's look at Mille a skill of the
commandment of faith she was 362 years
old before she was sealed away
however she wasn't a humanoid demon for
all that time molasse girl started out
as a small snake the snake bathe in
miasma from the demon world
she grew in size and eventually gained
the ability to take on a human form as
well after that she was chosen by the
demon king himself to be the commandant
of faith and she truly lived up to her
title she was arguably the most loyal of
all the 10 commandments because she had
the most unshakable faith in the demon
king she was present when the goddess
Elizabeth confronted Derry area and the
rest of the demons when Luna shall
revealed all of the demon hostages
trapped within the Ark magic molasse
claw was the one that commented on how
none of them were even fighters in the
war rather they were innocent civilians
she is very angry when lunar shell kills
all those innocent demons she is saved
by the land from the Omega Ark attack
then while the others continue to fight
she goes to help go thor transform the
gates to heaven go through is actually
tricking her though she thinks she's
helping to make it a gate to the demon
world but the doll Gotha is actually
turning it into a gate to demon prison
so the original demon Gotha can breakout
molasse killa is shocked when she
realizes that she has created a gate to
the prison of the demon world by mistake
and screams out go Thurs name in anger
molasse qila is extremely upset the
original gothert richter but the newly
freed demon uses magic to make sure she
keeps still so the demon Lords attention
is not drawn to them Milus kala is all
the more upset because as Gotha points
out she's a blind believer in the demon
king demon go third tricked her into
betraying the person she has complete
faith in it is truly the worst thing go
through could do to her from her point
of view after this you know the drill
she eventually gets sealed away with the
rest of the commandments next let's
tackle the commandments of selflessness
first the original go through and then
progerin who takes over after him demon
go third the commandment of selflessness
was a very powerful wizard he was
actually Merlins magic teacher when she
was young he saw that she had great
potential even then demon go through had
a lover named Clarissa she was one of
the innocent demons killed by the
Archangel mile five hundred years before
the holy Ward the demon king forcibly
bestowed the commandment of selflessness
on demon Gotha because he refused to be
the demon king's commandment and do his
bidding he was sent to demon world
prison he created go third a doll so
that he could experience the outside
world through him he made the doll in
the image of his lover but made it male
so that he wouldn't feel sexual desire
towards a doll he considered the doll to
be his masterpiece and he loved the dog
author as if he was his own son as we
saw he tricked molasse killer into
getting out of prison when zelda shows
up joel takes him on giving demon go
third a chance to escape with his doll
then he carries out his plan to stop the
holy war at least temporarily
he has his doll help him and together
they cast the biggest genjutsu they make
everyone including the gods a mile
himself believed that mile the archangel
is esther osa the middle son of the
demon king everyone was led to believe
that Esther osa killed mile mile was
picked because he was one of the
strongest fighters of the goddess clan
and because he was the one who killed
demon Gothas lover with someone as
strong as my LAN the demon
the goddesses were forced to use the
coffin of eternal darkness to seal away
the demons this required so much power
that the goddesses lost their ability to
maintain their physical forms thus came
the end of the holy war or at least a
three thousand year intermission demon
go through used the last of his life
force in order to use this forbidden
spell so he died after using it from
here the dog go through who had a
Pinocchio mode where he could act and
think for himself disappeared you can
see his full backstory in my every since
Baxter explained video but for now let's
move on to froderick Rajan was not
selected by the demon king like the
others he was more like a proxy
commandant a replacement for the demon
Gotha he was higher ranking than most
demons but still not as powerful as the
commandments were when Mele Otis the
oldest and most powerful son of the
demon king betrayed the demon clan for
Elisabeth the goddess Rajan was shocked
when gothert old him that Mellie Otis
did it for the sake of love and asked
Roger if he could relate to that Rajan
said that he could not as we saw if
Roger was with derrière II and the
others when they fought the Archangels
he was saved by montz Pete but he was
arguably the least useful in the battle
he wasn't even a commandant yet at that
point unlike the others fraud Jean was
sealed away by a goddess before the
others were sealed away in the coffin of
eternal darkness
sixteen years before the main story
takes place the people of Danna for
broke his seal and fraud Rijn escaped he
began working on freeing the rest of the
ten commandments Rajan attacked the city
of Danna for which rivaled Leonys and
power he nearly destroyed the kingdom
and even killed Liz who looked like the
goddess Elisabeth because she was her
106 'the reincarnation
Meli Odets off Roger and kill is his
love and he lost it giving way to his
wrath Mellie oldest wiped what remained
of the once powerful Kingdom off the
face of the earth Rajan managed to
survive this attack six years later when
Hendrickson and Rufus are investigating
the remains of Danna for Rajan is there
Roger tries to take over dreyfuses body
but can't so he takes over Hendrickson's
body instead then wanting to save his
student and friend
Dreyfuss willingly allows himself to be
taken over after getting Dreyfuss and
Hendrickson to kills a tatras the sins
are framed for it in
hisses body fraud run leads the holy
Knights against the sins in the decade
following serratus is that Roger and
Cher dreyfuses body and as a result
started to really care for dray passes
son Gris amore
as if he were his own son next let's
look at ester OSA the commandment of
love we got a glimpse of his backstory
from go Thurs backstory but let's look
at it in more detail as we know Esther
OSA was mild before the NGO Thurs used
their genjutsu to make everyone think
otherwise mal was one of the four
Archangels and Ludo shells younger
brother as a kid mile was extremely kind
and didn't want to harm anyone he
greatly admired his older brother Lou
Rochelle and aspired to be like him
later these memories would be confused
so that as Esther OSA he falsely
remembered that it was Mellie Otis that
he looked up to and admired mile also
met the goddess Elizabeth and fell in
love with her lunar shell promised that
he would help set the two of them up
however she fell in love with Mellie
Otis so it could never really work out
between her and Maya when he becomes
Estero so things are especially
confusing because Esther OSA falsely
remembers meliodas telling him that
he'll set mile up with Elizabeth
obviously Mellie Otis would never do
this though because he's madly in love
with Elizabeth himself mile went on with
his sunshine powers to become the
strongest Archangel even surpassing Ludo
show he easily overpowered belly on the
leader of the six nights of black but
could not do the same when Mellie Otis
showed up to fight him Mellie Otis
managed to make mile retreat at some
point as we saw with demon go there's
backstory mile killed Gophers lover
along with other innocent demons even
though he didn't like harming people as
a kid he was raised by the goddess clan
and lunar shell to believe that he was
doing the world and even the demons
themselves a favor by killing them
during the memories of the holy war Ark
lunar shell actually tells Niro basta to
call for Maya but he doesn't end up
making an appearance rather demon goat
her rescues himself from demon prison
and then uses the forbidden spell in
order to end a holy war demon goat her
tricks everyone including mile himself
into thinking that my L is actually esta
rosa
and that esther osa killed the real mile
as mentioned he picked mild because of
his immense level of power but also
because he murdered his lover Maya lost
his grace when he turned into a sterile
and he gained the commandment of love
the commandment die Mele Otis abandoned
when he left a demon clan in sided with
Elizabeth ironically the goddesses
sealed away their strongest fighter
without knowing it they sealed mile now
a serosa into the coffin of eternal
darkness along with the other
commandments mile was 380 years old when
he was sealed away last but not least we
have Zell drous the Commandant of piety
zelgius the executioner is the youngest
son of the demon king and younger
brother to Mele Otis he was 252 years
old when he was sealed away while Mele
Otis was mentored by Chandler zelgius
was mentored by Cusack like mile zelgius
idolized his elder brother was all just
really admired Mele Otis when he was the
leader of the ten commandments at some
point he fell in love with the vampire
gelda when Mele Otis was about to
abandon the demon clan zelgius
confronted him Mele Otis explained to
his low brother that he was doing it for
Elizabeth
the goddess woman he loved Mele Otis
actually invited zelgius to bring gelda
and come along however zelgius lived up
to his commandment of piety and refused
from this point on they'd be enemies
rather than brothers so it already seems
pretty bad for zelgius his older brother
who he greatly admired betrayed the
demon clan however it gets even worse
during the holy war the vampire clan
turned against the demon king as
punishment ljus the executioner was
ordered to kill them now zelgius had to
make a choice would he side with his
father or his lover now that they were
no longer on the same side unlike Mele
öitís zelgius seemingly chose to side
with his father nevertheless he couldn't
bring himself to kill gelda so he sealed
her away instead along with the other
vampires the rest we know sell just as
the demon Kings representative showed up
after daemon go thurs prison-break and
quickly defeated the giant king droll
despite his small size he managed to
beat Rahl so bad that the giant Kings
pride was crushed when Zell just offered
role a chance to join the 10
commandments droll took it soldiers led
the 10 commandments in melee Otis's
absence even after his false brother
Esther OSA joined the picture along with
the rest
he was sealed away by the goddesses as
you already know Mele Otis was also
commandant at one point but I won't
cover him here since I already covered
his backstory in detail into every sense
backstory explained video
put the link to that video in the
description and at the end of this video
if you're interested in his full
backstory and that is it for this video
thank you for watching these types of
videos always take quite a lot of time
and work so I would appreciate it if you
could leave a like if you enjoyed this
video and want to see more videos like
it also share this video with someone
who loves the seven deadly sins that
helps a lot if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is extremely
important hit that notification bell so
you actually know when you some of the
lessons videos come out and remember if
you want your vote to count follow us on
Instagram and anime up drawer and vote
for the best commandment right now there
can only be one champion and if you're
still with me I'd love to hear who your
favorite commandment is and why in the
comments let's say you can't pick Mele
Otis because I know most people would
rightly pick our opie protagonist if
they could a big thank you goes out to
our patrons over on patreon who help
make videos like this one possible I'm
blown away by the amount of patrons we
have and I'm extremely thankful to each
and every one of you I especially want
to thank our pro hero to your patrons
the one and only Gilgamesh baby ray
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson kings
I'll just $30 beat at Karachi and
Anatoly Cassatt's key DJ Nathaniel alpha
do and angel Cruz and are the one tier
patrons the ones who stay atop all clans
Stephen and Radha allo Lana 10 Maddy Mac
239 makoto-kun Seth Cooper and the world
if you enjoy work you can support more
of it by going over to patreon comm
anime out drawer and becoming a patron
today for as little as $1 if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you're leaving at access
for private patient only discord so
check out patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]